It's tempting to think of the ocean as a
domain of quiet or Jacques Cousteau
himself,
called it the silent world,
but in fact,
the sea is full of noise.
Sea Mammals,
crustaceans,
diving birds,
and a number of fish communicate with
pulses of sound.
Dolphins,
as we all know from the modern cinematic
masterpiece flipper use echolocation
Dolphin's sonar.
So you flipped her sense of of sound
toward an object and receives an echo
back he can see in total darkness.
Yeah,
about 20 million years after Dolphins
mastered echolocation.
It occurred to human beings that the
skill might have some use when a young
man named Leonardo dicaprio drowned
needlessly in the ocean following an
unfortunate incident with the ship.
I can't remember the name of sonar or
sound navigation and ranging is only one
of the ways that human beings have
doubled noise levels in the ocean every
decade since the mid 20th century.
What was once the exclusive domain of
clicks,
wines and whale songs is now throng with
the thunder of ship propellers,
ultra loud naval sonar and seismic
surveys of oil and gas companies,
which blast air guns so loud,
they penetrate kilometers into the ocean
floor so loud that they are a million
times more intense than that.
Sounds good.
The effect of such deafening noise is
devastating to the oceans ecosystem,
and by extension the world's at large.
It is particularly destructive to Wales
who use low frequency noises to
communicate across large distances,
trapped in that disorienting.
Could Kaufmanni whales swim dive
erratically,
radically causing decompression sickness
and mass strandings on nearby beaches.
In July of this year of the Obama
administration authorized Seismic Aragon
testing for an unprecedented swath of
the Atlantic Ocean.
Something that government itself
determined would injure more than
138,000
dolphins and whales,
including the North Atlantic right whale
of which and where there are only a
meager 500 left.
My charity for the 2014 project for
awesome is the largest international
advocacy organization focused solely on
ocean conservation.
They have the resources,
the coordination,
and a laundry list of victories against
the admittedly huge interests that
degrade RC everyday.
You know,
100 years ago we had no fear that what
we did could affect the vastness of the
ocean than a few of our bravest went up
into space and the pictures they took,
their gave us an urgent new perspective
helping us to see that the world which
made us could buy us the unmet.